welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens and this is a breakdown
of echo episode 4 titled tooa that's
after Maya's mom last episode we saw
Kingpin arrive in what felt like a green
screenshot regardless Kingpin has
entered the chat and in this episode
we'll explore a couple of things one how
the heck did Ekko get her powers two can
kingpen see in both eyes and three does
he own Avengers Tower so let's quit
Lolly gagging and get into it but first
don't forget to check out nerd rot. shop
where right now you can find merch
inspired by the echo series including a
shirt featuring the big man himself a
shirt with Echo spelled out in ASL with
bloody knuckles it's 2008 and we're in
New York City the big NY the Big Apple
along with young mayia going to a
private school and being accompanied by
Wilson FIS this is a year that Tony's
abducted as a change of heart and we see
the Mark 1 2 and three suits we also see
the Duel of Los Angeles AKA you know
when like Tony Stark and obadias danain
really just messed up our city so a
quiet year in New York but a freaking
show over in the City of Angels
Maya steps out in her school uniform and
little prosthetic leg we've seen this
scene in the trailer but not much detail
from it and there's also a New York Post
Box behind them and this ice cream guy
is kind of a in one of the
Hawkeye deleted scenes Fisk offers to
get ice cream with Mya after karate
while her dad is busy doing his work so
this was her comfort and tradition with
f excluding you know the half dead ice
cream man who gets beat to a pulp in
front of her additionally I like how FIS
just Yanks this man into an alley in
straight up daylight the last thing we
see before this man gets his Dome rocked
his frozen treats doesn't know yet that
he's about to get a frozen beat down I
mentioned Fisk wearing that damn white
suit in the first episode episode and
I'll mention again here because he
thinks he's slick wearing the same
outfit twice we see the bloody hand that
we saw on the trailer I've mentioned
this also before but we hadn't seen
kingpin's Infamous cuffing since the
finale of Hawkeye when Kate did Clint's
coin trick even in this shot we don't
see them just the Rings that's been on
this entire season this could be the new
form of cufflinks they do resemble them
with the dark stud in the center in the
teaser footage that was released for
Ekko that had clips from Daredevil is
strategically edited around the scenes
that show the cufflinks so I think
they're now rings so after reacting
carelessly he smashes this man's head
and asks for forgiveness and then moves
on just like he did with Vanessa and
that Russian guy whose head he slammed
repeatedly between a car door until he
beheaded him cuz you know old habits die
hard I guess with Wilson Fisk before
seeing Maya he calls someone on the
phone yes I need a new jacket this could
be Melvin Potter who Fisk had making his
suits back in the day during Daredevil
or it could be his little Wesley
his personal assistant who was there
every step of the way Maya's watching
just like the dragon and clearly she's
picked up a new vibe from her uncle and
all the crime she's been around she gets
a couple of good licks in on the ice
cream man then walks away hand inand
with Fisk jump to 2021 Fisk and M are
having their weekly Sunday dinners when
he basically promotes her he reveals
that they can only trust each other and
I'll be honest Fisk is clearly an
emotional man who wears his heart on his
sleeve you think he'd be smarter with
that big ass head of his in the
background is a piece of art featuring
the stars from the American flag and
some Hammers If there's two things
Wilson Fisk loves it's America and
hammers this is some foreshadowing to a
very important Hammer that will come
back at the end of the episode we also
see why the translator has changed at
least twice and it's because he's
killing them after he's done with them
he literally Lally escorted her to her
plastic bag death and then killed her we
actually get to hear her like beg for
her life and it's horrible please please
let go Honestly though horrible I do
like this little detail it's a nice
touch because I wondered what if he told
Maya he was going to blow up the moon
would the translator like Tell The
President this is all where I put my
don't shoot the messenger joke but I
don't have to it speaks for itself
though I do feel bad for these women and
Julie from Daredevil season 3 they did
absolutely nothing and they keep just
dying back to the present Fisk is at
Maya's house waiting on her with his
goons they place a contact in her eye
allowing her to see virtual ASL that
auto translates whatever Fisk is saying
it captures your face forearms and hands
and when it tries to recognize fisk's
eye the right eye gets a little red
diamond it's attempting to reconnect and
can't Source his retinas I think the
closest thing we had to digital
translator in the MCU was the Creed Tech
that Carol quill and later the rest of
the Guardians had the translator would
autot translate various languages cuz
they were always in space they don't
speak English in space not all the
places I think the closest we'd get to
this translator regarding engineering
are the Edith glasses especially
especially how it scanned your retina
recognizing the user as it did for Peter
also later in the top left corner it
looks like a symbol of two hands and
faint letters saying ASL so this is
probably originally a device to
translate languages and you could roll
through them like a Rolodex the ASL
could be the new commission accessory
that fist talked about but this is just
a working Theory I'm only assuming this
because we're still trying to figure out
who owns Avengers Tower and if this
translator and the eye patch were pieces
of the tech left behind I wouldn't be
surprise naturally we all imine pepper
pots would have liquidated everything
but what if she didn't what if she left
behind the smaller that does nothing or
what if Tony had left something behind
with information about new prototype
Tech then it would be easier for fist to
move in and create from Tony's history
that he left behind additionally it's
not like a disgruntled employee hasn't
left Stark Industries before stinking of
Revenge and could be working under Fisk
but I want to believe my first Theory
just because anything is really possible
and I think that's more possible Fisk
and Maya go inside and then Fisk Reveals
His damaged eye why did he wait to go in
the house to do it why is he wearing the
bandage all the freaking time if he
doesn't need it why is he so dramatic I
hate Wilson pist when he began removing
moving the bandage it lit up blue and
had a subtle electronic hum the same
blue light and electronic hum as the
Regeneration cradle made by Helen Cho in
Age of
Ultron you sure he's going to be this
device fixed Clint's leg helped ultron's
vibranium body and created Vision later
it was destroyed but that doesn't mean
the pieces blueprints or prototypes were
it could still live in Avengers Tower I
think this could be a big hint as we're
still waiting to see who actually owns
it and also hey look I get it no one has
touched this house but that clock still
says 8:35 which is the same time of
death when Maya's mom died or at least
when they left the house to go get hot
chocolate why are these batteries just
they're just dead they're just dead and
stayed the same time for like years Maya
pours the wine down the sink probably to
keep him and her with a clear head
however we haven't really seen Maya
really drink this entire show like drink
alcohol at the Fisk family dinner she's
usually standing menacingly or just
looking at him menacingly at one point
it looks like her wine glass actually
has water in it rather than alcohol so
she might not drink kingin offers Le
Fett wine which can range from $300 a
nice measly $300 to $188,000 allegedly
and kingin says this what happened to
the
lefet they came highly recommended as we
remember from Daredevil season 1 he
doesn't know how to buy wine he only
takes recommendations because he's
unrefined Wesley told him how to shop
for Vanessa's wine he doesn't know what
he's talking about maybe I should be out
with him instead they enjoy some Shasta
Cola and leevan cookies real beloved
cookies from New York City that I think
producer Evan really loves a lot he
speaks highly of them he says are really
good but also very bougie then Fisk
offers her an Empire with him he's
flying out tomorrow and is staying at
the Chaka Casino we see it later and
this is actually the design for the
actual chak T casinos then he leaves
giving her the obvious decision to not
take it Henry closed the skating rink
the next day probably because he was
busy cleaning Vicky's blood from the
floor something I've noticed that's been
addressed in recent interviews is Henry
usually speaks out loud when he's
signing and so does Scully and biscuit
sometimes they'll take a second to
remember how to sign something this
among other scenes is great attention to
detail in an interview with total film
director Sydney fre mentions how varying
people in Maya's life are more fluent in
ASL than others people who are less
proficient will also speak at the same
time it's called simcom so they tried to
make a spectrum of experiences in Maya's
family to be more authentic also these
actors learn sign language from
eternal's ASL consultant Doug ridloff
who is the husband of the actress who
played Mari too bad for you Barry kogan
beautiful beautiful Mari my ass if
you're looking to ring in the New Year
by ringing in a New Year revamping your
daily hygiene routine is the best place
to start and geology is here to help
your New Year resolution with new Skin
Care Solutions ding geology is a 29 time
award-winning skin hair body care
company recognizing Men's Health Oprah
daily hype Beast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology products use just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiliness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
and I mean is it really a new year if
you don't age I mean I don't think so if
you don't know where to start geology
can create a simple and effective
skincare or hair care routine for you
all you got to do is take a quick 30
second quiz 30 seconds that's nothing
you are free and I know you are free for
at least 30 seconds right now if you use
code new rock stars 100 geology will
give you 100% off of their award-winning
skincare trial set
100% off you are out of your mind do you
guys know how to do math you also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body product when you
add it to your trial so 100% % off plus
an additional 30% off I hope you save
some champagne because this deal is
worth celebrating I'm about to pop some
bottles click the link in the
description or go to G log. i/ rockstars
100 to get started Henry then has a
heart-to- heart with Maya about trying
to leave and fist threatens to kill him
if he does as we know from the finale of
Hawkeye in this show Fisk will track you
down and kill you if you threaten to
leave him everyone's afraid of it we've
seen bits and pieces but they're finally
setting up the chock up how wow cholo
Was preparing for it with other
organizers in the last episode and we
saw a post forward in the first episode
a is a time and a place to learn and
celebrate Native American culture
specifically here for the chucktown
nation then we see some real sites it's
at the hasco county fairgrounds which is
a real place in subl Kansas and teetan
trade cloth by Lenape is a real shop
native owned and woman-owned creating
Indian artwork wool trade cloth trade
beads and other rare finds then Chola
gets a flashback of her ancestors like
we've seen throughout with Maya then at
the same time mea receives the same
Visions at Henry's most of these are new
images for us as well a canopy of trees
and the sunlight beaming through them
pregnant woman on a stretcher the
pregnant woman giving birth in the woods
the spiral we've seen now has etching
then cuts to a wide shot so we see the
top of the cave that collapsed in the
first episode then I think mayia faints
and Henry takes her to her grandmother's
I don't know if everyone knows Cha's
powers or she's just known as the town
Grandma who can fix everything I think
it's alluded to her family knowing Chola
has a firm connection with the ancestors
though because after maa's Visions Henry
didn't take her to a hospital or
Gretchen he was like only one person can
fix this child's inner demons all it
took for these two to finally talk was
Henry dropping her off and saying get
the hell out of here inside chol's home
she offers popping cookies like Maya
didn't just have that exact meal last
night with FIS in the background chol's
fridge is a fox drawing probably because
chol's name means Fox the more you know
we learned that Maya's mom barely made
it and her grandma and labor left the
hospital to a midwife and gave birth to
Maya's mom tooa who was a Healer and the
generations are echoing to Maya and
coming when Maya or Chola need them the
most I couldn't find much on the Midwife
process in Chaka tradition but this
scene is beautiful it's mentioned in an
interview with Seth Fairchild that there
are some things in chock on nation that
can't be expressed in the series and
maybe this is one of them my storms out
and Chola heads into her Studio they
mentioned that she used to have a shop
in the second episode when prepping for
the powwow Nita you know Chola store has
been closed down for a while now in the
studio we see a lot of different Fringe
clothing I think she makes the regalia
dresses the number 12 on the mannequin
might represent the 12 districts of the
Chakan Nation then down to the river to
prey plays which respectfully my family
is from Tennessee and Mississippi and
hearing this song again triggers
something in me that I can't listen to
the song anymore I want to throw my head
through the computer the exact origins
of this song though are unknown with it
often being attributed to
African-American spirituals from the
19th century with the earliest version
of this song being written down in 1867
the version used here is performed by
Allison Krauss and was featured in the
Cohen Brothers film Oh Brother Where Art
Thou you remember that movie it was very
funny as we see a sad Chola Maya on her
bike again Bonnie aad at chol's house in
her kitchen biscuit is still trying to
fix Cha's car at a Car Lot he refers to
Chola as pkne that's chak for Grandma
Woody also quotes The Lion King his
name's Woody he quotes The Lion King and
this is all just ridiculous then we get
this very deep moment that sums up what
we should expect in the finale episode
you know what you're looking
for I'll know when I find it Chola
always says there's nothing too broke to
fix if you want it bad enough don't
throw it away Chola is currently
designing an outfit that we will see
Mayan later and I will break it down
then because it's spectacular and we
need to see it in better lighting Maya
rode all the way to the casino to kill
Kingpin presumably the gospel music
that's just playing over her about to
assassinate someone is crazy to me it
says show me the way and it's down the
barrel of a freaking gun he's put the
bandage bag on his eye and I suspect
it's healing 24/7 or just makes him more
comfortable I hate how Kingpin is trying
to tell her we only had each other at
one point like he wasn't the reason for
that the psychological abuse and
manipulation Fisk is imprinting on Maya
right now like the entire series it
sucks and I'm glad she's confronting him
about it in this scene between Natasha
yena Gora nebula now Eko like these men
manipulating these girls and lying to
them from such young ages that stuff
doesn't go away they just grow from
those emotions that could lead to a ton
of mental health problems behavioral
problems basically turning them into
other kingpins it doesn't also stop at
like girls it's shuni moonight Star-Lord
the list goes on it's horrible because
we really don't have a solution for it
in the MCU these Heroes just grow from
these traumas and I wish I wish they
could all help each other or just talk
to each other then when I think he's
about to pull out his cuff Lings he
shows off the hammer the hammer and
you're right one of these things are not
like the other the hammer from Ekko and
the hammer from Daredevil are two
different things the echo one is
prettier why did they change it I have
no idea I can't even theorize why they
would but they did Hector on inside
Marvel mentioned the change of hammer
being a thematic change rather than an
obvious one thematically thematically a
framing hammer is something that is used
to normally like build a house right
Wilson fist 12-year-old use a framing
hammer to tear down that house oh my God
and in the present a ballpen hammer a
ballpen hammer is more often used in a
way to kind of Forge metal or a weapon
shape metal so he's trying to shape Maya
into a weapon for himself so that's why
thematically I'm just trying to like
more this make it so that there's
there's not a continuity ER not a
continuity area it's on purpose okay he
proposes to Maya the generous gift of
beating him to death like he did his
father with the hammer and honestly
would that even kill him would it even
kill him he was shot in the face and
survived so truly would he die from a
hammer to the Head regardless she's not
like him so she throws the hammer back
down we knew from the teaser trailer
that Kingpin story of killing his father
and make its way into the Disney MCU via
Echo but him carrying the hammer is wild
what is he Thor then Maya leaves
questioning whether she should go with
Kingpin the next day at the lake by her
house she Ponders and we see flashes of
Kingpin sitting with her at karate in
the car after the motorcycle accident
he's laughing at the family dinner but
she also remembers the bad times like
fighting Clint on top of the roof with
yena and Kate Bishop from Hawkeye fat
man's auto repair when Clint told her
the truth on the bridge with the
tracksuit Mafia shooting at Clint and
Kate quicker cuts of the motorcycle
through the shop window the security
guards of the drug Den her shooting at
Clint at the auto repair in Hawkeye what
director Sydney Freeland calls the birth
of a villain kingf tells her I love you
and Hawkeye after talking to ellan our
Bishop she says it back uh but I I
understand is a hostage at the skating
ring her family is in literal danger the
time she had biscuit tracking her on the
train destroying Grandma's car Bonnie
seeing her for the first time in years
quicker cuts the Skully Chola her dying
father her mother all of these play
major factors in her life her family and
crime are the only life she's ever known
the misjudgment and manipulation this
girl has been every way but up and now
she's finally getting a chance to make a
decision for herself and we hope she
chooses right when you're in the dark as
long as my has been it's hard to see
your way out and sometimes just
disappearing sounds like a good idea the
hardest thing is super superhero can do
is protect their family and from all
those quick cutaways I assume she's only
got one real family worth the effort so
we've got to hope she continues on a
path of curiosity and that Curiosity
puts her down a path of becoming a hero
she leaves tomaha and other than the
Chaka National seal on the a of tomaha
we see Chapa Lai which means until we
meet again then we're taken to the
tarmac with the plane and Maya ain't
coming kingpin's men say they lost track
of her and kingpin's a kid who is just
lost his toy and is super angry right
now and about to break his own plane
during the closing credits we hear the
song bread and cheese from the group
hallucination and featuring black bear a
group from Canada who performed
traditional First Nation music these two
groups often collaborate to combine
electronic dance music and Hip-Hop with
indigenous music and it is it is so good
it's it's honestly really good please go
look it up it's it's so good me and
Brandon were listening to it there also
a ton of Daredevil moves happening in
this series in this episode Kingpin is
still aligned completely with his crazy
murderous rampaging self that we saw all
the way back then in Daredevil him
killing the translator threatening
everyone making shitty deals and
commissions is still very Daredevil
Kingpin and that's it for my breakdown
on episode 4 of Ekko tune in tomorrow
for my episode 5 breakdown oh that's the
end of it for us oh and follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu Clemens
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love check out the break
room where we'll be covering Echo all
this week thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
he